you guys ready for my aunt yeah yes
all right first aunt she likes cream
barbecue
wears bikinis around the house her name
is aunt selena
what's some facts on the scent she knows
she likes korean barbecue obviously
wears bikini
what are some facts let's go to chin for
the facts dude this lady's korean
is she korean no no she's just like
elena's not a crew
yeah that's pretty much it so she likes
korean bbq where's bikinis around the
house and this was submitted by
steven uh korean steven he might be
she's inked up too wearing bikinis
around the house so he's strange
well first of all she has a tattoo of
the the kid from the addams family on
her hip can you zoom in on that guy yeah
fester atoms whatever that is
and but very beautiful i love the
lattice work behind you you can see
water back behind her if you notice that
is there water back there oh you know um
actually in the midwest they do have a
flooding problem right now so maybe
that's what's going on here
what she's in bikini selena
in the midwest first of all hopefully
that's not her
uh the person who runs her fan club that
little boy with her because
that person will kill her have you seen
selena oh
you're right the manager shot her for no
reason at all yeah dude you're the worst
mexican i've ever met you're right
uh first of all shout out to all of our
mexican friends um
welcome to america and uh
and yeah selena very sad very very sad
first of all a lot of great latino
singers
die uh selena ritchie valance
uh la bamba uh ricky martin ricky martin
rest in peace yeah senor mr t mr t
very sad man but yeah selena got them
you know got them leches hot tamales
yeah yeah
con quesos
you're the worst spanish person ever man
i'm not spanish bro yeah you are no dude
i'm wider than you dude you know how
mexican you are i look mexican
bro 80 yeah maybe dude
i get a lot of weird looks you know yeah
brothers aren't weird looks those are
mexican
friends bro those are probably gang
bangers papa
no when i pull into home depot
everyone's like hey i'm like all right
dude i don't need any work but they just
like there's our mascot almost he's
doing at home
[Music]
dude he made it home seriously
bro next life bro i'm telling you i'm
coming police and i'll be done i'm being
mexican next time boy you want to be
mexican
santa claus yeah this is not close yeah
santa claus coming down the chimney papa
no we're stopping you at the border dude
you're you're done shout out two times
beautiful aunt selena thank you for
taking care you got a
wish like that my aunt looks like
[ __ ] my ass look like dragons
[Music]